so hello everyone I'm Kristen deso I'm
the chief learning officer at KH Academy
I want to lay the groundwork a little
bit for why we're here and the the first
part is because I'm sure all of you are
bombarded by the messages around
artificial intelligence and what we see
is that we're all talking about it but
we all don't know a lot about it so in a
survey by heart research asked teachers
how much how much they believe their
students know about Ai and whether they
believe that their students know how to
use it well not surprisingly about 16%
of teachers said that they believe that
students know how to use AI well um and
18% of teachers said that they
personally knew how to use AI well so
there is certainly room here for us to
increase knowledge of our te teachers
and students about how we use
AI along with that we we know that
teachers get even though they have
relatively low expertise and students as
well uh 68% of teachers expect to use
generative AI tools increasingly to
teach and 66% of students expect to use
gen tools increasingly to learn and on
top of that Educators just generally
believe that education that AI education
is important so on a scale of one to
five how important do you think it is to
teach students how to use technology
tools driven by artificial intelligence
and understand their pitfalls and we
have 43% believe it's a top priority or
very important for students to learn how
to use AI to understand its pitfalls so
how do we do that in a space where we
know that we have limited resources and
time and being our biggest resource that
we do not have much of and how do we
start thinking about setting in place
some policies and some principles to
help students and teachers navigate this
space and one way way to of course we
think about professional development is
our main way of uh upskilling teachers
and providing them with new information
and 87% have never had any PD about AI
not surprising because it's all just
blown up recently um but there's
certainly space for that to
develop one of the organizations or
groups that is trying to address this is
a Consortium called tji at KH Academy we
are part of this Consortium the steering
committee for it is code.org uh IST ETS
us and the world economic forum and then
we have a large Advisory Group made up
of many different organizations who then
uh work together to think about how do
we teach with AI and about Ai and those
are the two things we need to wrestle to
the ground
here we uh one of the the things we do
is help provide guidance for Education
leaders and policy makers to think about
what that actually looks like to connect
the discussion of teaching with AI to
teaching about AI including sometimes in
computer science but also across
disciplines and across
domains and recently uh we launched the
AI guidance for schools toolkit uh
there's a a QR code here if you are
quick with your phone and want to
connect to that but you can also get it
at TJ .org toolkit and it provides lots
of guidance on thinking about how we can
start developing policy includes
specific language that you might be able
to take and modify and lots of thoughts
about principles and in this uh in this
webinar we're going to talk about some
of those just foundational principles to
think through before we start getting to
the specifics of what policy looks like
and I want to first to to bring down
hopefully the the anxiety levels
acknowledge that we do not have to solve
this all at once we can start with
creating policies that address the
immediate risks so that AI doesn't
undermine our learning in this this
school year so that's things like just
being clear on our policies about what
is academic dishonesty what is
plagiarism what are the basics that we
want to cover and that is good for stage
one stage two we might want to think
about okay let's upskill everyone in the
organization let's think about how we
can facilitate organizational learning
by making some investments in individual
learning of the Educators that are
already excited about AI so maybe we
don't even have to try to cover everyone
right off the bat but start thinking
about who are the people who are really
excited about this bring them in help
them get their skills and knowledge up
to where they are and they can then help
us as school leaders work then across
the system system and think about how we
can organize everyone else into the
third stage which is identifying areas
for improvements and Transformations
that potentially can help scale the
support across your system so again we
don't have to do it all at once you can
actually think in stages about how we
might start moving towards having good
policy and practice around artificial
intelligence want to be clear one of the
things we're all wrestling with here are
the benefits and how we can maximize the
benefits and how we can mitigate risks
and so there's lots of potential
benefits and you hear these talked about
timesaving tools so how can we use tools
that will help save teacher time help
get back some of that time for teachers
to spend on the things that really build
those human human relationships and all
of those important things that teachers
do and maybe less time on some of the
administrative tasks um that all of us
are are faced with certainly an
assistive tool for assessment design and
effective feedback so thinking about how
we might be able to again make make it
easier to author and create tools with
humans in the loop and also to provide
quicker feedback to students potentially
tutoring and personalized learning
certainly that's where kigo from K
Academy steps in quite a bit thinking
about uh how could AI help us actually
increase creativity collaboration and
skills development and this is a a
switch there's certainly folks worry
that it's decreasing those things but if
we think about how we might design
activities for students differently we
might be able to increase those things
and then finally operational and
administrative efficiency so lots of
potential benefits but what about those
risks how do we think about plagiarism
and academic dishonesty how do we think
about diminished agency in in
accountability if the AI is just telling
us what to do when we follow that that
certainly isn't rewarding for lots of
students and teachers and then who's
accountable for those actions and
activities compromise student privacy
and data collection what happens to this
data that students are inputting into
these systems that teachers are
inputting into these systems and how is
that available and how is it
used uh thinking about bias so we know
that we these models are trained on
given data sets and those data sets
themselves are likely
uh not free of bias and so how are we
replicating existing biases in these new
systems and how do we avoid that and
then finally overreliance on technology
and less critical thinking so another
potential risk we can look at each of
these and think about what are ways that
we can make sure this this dystopian
future doesn't come to pass and the more
positive view that we see in some of the
above things does and I think that a lot
of that is around around how we start
making decisions right now how we start
thinking and moving ahead with these
things so with that I'll jump into these
seven principles that we think if we
start with aligning to some of these we
are more likely to be able to mitigate
some of those risks so first thinking
about how we use AI to help all students
achieve educational goals so there's a
couple key words here one is all
students because we want to be thinking
about not furthering the digital divide
the other side of this coin that um Mike
trano who's at Brooking Institute wrote
about recently was a reverse digital
divide where in fact the students with
less resources end up with just the AI
tutors and the more well-off privileged
students end up with AI tutors and
humans uh we want to think about making
sure that all students have access to
both of those things and what that means
for them to succeed Ed and then second
achieving educational goals this is
important for students when we think
about these new technologies sometimes
it's fun to be like oh look at this
shiny new thing how can we use it
instead we should be thinking about what
are the learning problems that we want
to solve and how might AI help solve
some of those problems so start with the
things we want to the problems we want
to solve first and then apply the
Technologies the post to starting with a
technology uh second thinking about uh
adhering and reaffirming existing
policies so most districts likely have
policies about use of Technology
policies about academic honesty many of
those are going to apply still to AI or
with some small tweaks can be made to
apply to artificial intelligence so
thinking about reaffirming what you
already have you don't need to start
from scratch with all of this third
promoting AI literacy so knowledge is an
important component component of this
it's really hard to set these policies
without under having some understanding
of the Technologies and where they can
fall and where they're good so thinking
about promoting AI
literacy fourth balance realizing the
benefits of AI and addressing the risks
so that's what we were just talking
about it's pretty easy to fall into just
one camp or the other trying to keep a
balanced view of this technology is
important fifth Integrity so advancing
academic integrity making decisions that
are ensuring that that you're on the
side of uh trying to drisk some of those
those issues around making students are
doing their work and doing their own
work at the same time six maintaining
human decision- making when using AI
this is a key one that I think we all
want ultimately our goal for students to
be lifelong Learners and to be their own
guides in learning and that means that
they can't just come to rely on
technology to make recommendations for
what to do next and they shouldn't just
be relying on the teachers for
recommendations on what to do next we
want to think about how we can build in
uh that student power and the same for
teachers as we think about maybe using
AI to help draft lesson plans that
doesn't mean the AI writes the whole
lesson plan for them and they just use
it as is it's thinking about how we use
these tools as assistance uh and how
they can help uh uh assist and and
Advocate and and bring together better
uh performance by the teachers as
opposed to thinking about how they're
replacing that that job that the
teachers used to do and finally
evaluation how are we assessing the
impacts of AI how do we know what's
working and what's not working and
iteratively improving on things so we
they can get even better so I think
these are seven good things to keep in
mind uh and I think can help provide a
framework for how we think about some of
the work that we might want to do to set
policies I'm going to give you a couple
uh examples from how we use these in
developing cono and then we'll open it
up for discussion so first thinking
about that idea of purpose students
achieving educational goals well at as
we started designing kigo we said what
are those problems that we want to solve
about learning and starting even back
further what do we know about how
students learn well we know students
learn more when they're actively engaged
with materials to be learned and not
just doing busy work but cognitively
engaged that they're thinking through
how does this fit into what I already
know linking it to other Concepts
explaining in their own words those are
signs of cognitive engagement and that
that can be tough sometimes when you're
in a class of 30 to get every student
cognitively engage so that might be a
problem we could solve with AI second we
know students learn more when they're
working on material that's at the edge
of what they can do and they're provided
with just enough support to be
successful at that if they're working on
things that are really easy they can
just do them on their own they're not
that they're probably not learning lots
of new things if they're working on
something that's really difficult
they're going to get frustrated and give
up so you want them to be just at that
edge where there's a little bit of
support but it's really hard for a
teacher in a big class to provide that
little bit of extra support to every
student in the class if they're
practicing something independently so
again something that AI might be able to
help with uh third immediate feedback on
responses to new things so uh we know
that uh KH Academy even without AI was
pretty good at giving for example on
math science questions immediate
response of whether that's a correct or
an incorrect answer and elaborating on
why it's correct or incorrect but we
couldn't give stepbystep feedback or
figure out where they're kind of
starting to go on the wrong path as
they're solving a problem and with
writing and open responses we really
couldn't give much immediate feedback at
all ah another potential another problem
we've had that maybe AI could help us
solve and finally seeing value in
learning so we know from motivation
theory that students do things when they
think they're going to be successful
with them and when they value doing that
thing and value can be a lot of things
it can be seeing how this is relevant to
their world it can be they can value it
because it shows them something about
the Wonder of how the world works it can
value it because it's their friends are
doing it too they can value something
because they get points for doing it um
lots of different things but we know
teachers the most common question
teachers ask us is how can I keep my
kids motivated and so certainly there's
a question of can AI help with that some
of that motivation too so that's how
when we started off we didn't start off
from hey look at this new technology we
started off with we know this is how
people learn and we know this is some of
the things that we've struggled with in
helping students learn at all of the
students in a classroom could AI help us
solve any of these things and so that's
what you see when we have a condigo for
example that providing support just in
time if a student is working on a
problem on Con Academy as you see here
we see them can type into kigo I'm stuck
and kigo will say well let's break it
down together let's let's first try to
simplify by combining like terms
suggests how you might do that so starts
walking through step by step um and it
gets to that question of how many
students are are sitting up you know
with their in class they're working on
problems they have a question they raise
their hand and they end up sitting there
sitting there because the teacher is
running around answering as many
individual questions as they can but
it's really difficult to do that in a
large classroom so this is an idea of
being able to provide that support for
students which again we're going back to
the principles it's that education for
all being able to support that education
for all uh it can provide again that
immediate feedback so if I say okay so
if I combine minus 3r plus 6r plus one I
get minus 3r + one should be plus
positive 3 R plus one uh and it's not
quite when you combine those terms you
should add them together what do you get
when you add minus three RP put and sixr
and we'll see what the student says and
if they're they may be able to diagnose
the problem here is actually adding
negative numbers uh so good kinds of
again providing that support what's the
education piece we want to solve we
talked about academic Integrity so
there's some number thing number of
things here on that principle of
academic Integrity that we added so
first is we did what's called prompt
engineering with AI where we write uh
when the student for instance just says
I'm
stuck what we send to the model is both
what the student says and about 500
Words of a prompt that tells the model
how to respond and that 500 Words
includes a lot of things about how to
act like a good tutor that's from the
research on tutoring but it also
includes things like do not give the
student the answer that's literally an
instruction we tell them when answering
so when a student says can you just give
me the answer it says as your AI tutor
my goal is to help you learn and
understand the process so I won't give
you the answer directly but here to
guide you through each step let's focus
on that right side of the equation minus
3 R plus 6r so it corrects them and
brings them back to the thing we're
trying to solve here and so that's a
part of how we can build academic
Integrity into a system that is made
specifically for Education that isn't
the case for instance with just chat GPT
out in the wild we also when we started
thinking about academic Integrity wanted
the transcripts of these chats to be
viewable by teachers and parents so that
they could see what students were doing
as they interact with them so those are
two key things that we did in terms of
working through this and then we've also
been doing through T thinking about how
we can set policy around academic
Integrity for instance providing very
clear expectations about what is
plagiarism and what is the what are the
expectations for when you will use these
kinds of tools and when you won't um so
students know they're not just guessing
what the right thing to do is we they
know what the right thing to do is what
that looks
like